I had a friend in Albany and she called
me.
She said,
Robert Moses was up here yesterday and I
think you should come back,
and I remember driving up to Albany and
walking into the press gallery of the
assembly just as they approved the
bridge by a vote of something like 183
to four,
and I remember thinking in that moment
everything I've been writing has sorta
been baloney because whether you say it
or not in an article,
everything I was doing was based on the
feeling that ended democracy.
Political power comes from the ballot
box from being elected from the people.
Yet here was a man who was never elected
to anything and enough power to turn in
an entire state government around in a
single day and I had no idea and
actually neither did anybody else where
he got this power from.
And it was then that.
I thought that if I really wanted to
write about politics,
truthfully I have to find out because no
one knew where he got his power and how
we had been using it for so long.